mon nom est docteur william moulton
marston et je suis le créateur de wonder
woman wonder woman est une lettre
d'amour
[Musique]
une personne est plus heureuse si elle
est soumise à une autorité qu'elle
affectionne j'ai envie de l'étudier elle
va te briser le coeur je ne serai pas
jalouse je suis ton épouse batna
geôliers je crois que vous avez envie
d'une vie non conventionnés peut-être
que je la veux seulement parce que tulle
est ce que tu crois c'est possible
d'aimer deux personnes en même temps
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la normalité ce que nous
voulons ne pourra jamais un client
le monde ne l'interdira
[Musique]
le monde ne peut pas nous en empêcher
est ce que c'est ce que tu veux dans
tous les numéros de wonder woman
les femmes sont fous et tfc a enchaîné
ligoté bâillonné comportement anormal
dans les pages de votre comité de la
conscience
une femme ne pourra jamais recevoir sa
liberté jusqu'à ce qu'elle l'acquiert si
tu tiens absolument à comprendre
l'esprit d'une femme commence avec ça tu
es brillante elle un coeur pur ball
intense à vous deux vous êtes la femme
parfaite prenant roumaine a une identité
secrète ou tel réseau
elle doit cacher sa vraie personnalité
au monde
que se passerait-il si l'identité
secrète de wonder woman était rêvée tous
seraient perdus je me demande si ce
n'est pas plutôt vos qui avait une
identité secrète
[Musique]